[Music]
good afternoon
and Rafa arrived MIT is president number
17 to all of Paul's friends and
colleagues to the gray family enjoy
beloved Priscilla it's an honor to open
the celebration of pause remarkable life
all of us are gathered here because of
Paul but in a larger sense a must point
out that I'm here at MIT because of him
that may be true for many of you too
for me it's because in the 1980s MIT was
in a fierce competition with other top
academic institutions for leadership in
electrical engineering as president for
understood that MIT
urgently needed to create what we ended
up calling MTL the Microsystems
technology laboratories launching MTL
had the important effect of keeping MIT
at the front front forefront of the
field and incidentally it kept me here
on the faculty some a direct beneficiary
of Paul's clear vision and exceptional
ability to get things done as you can
see from your programs our speakers
today and the program itself explore
many dimensions of Paul's life story so
I will not attempt to capture it myself
instead I will reflect on a few lessons
he taught us all through the eloquence
of his example we all know that Paul
held just about every job at MIT
including finally the chairman of the
corporation after that he went back to
the job he loved the most teaching
naturally he returned to his home
discipline electrical engineering at the
time the associate department head for
electrical engineering was some micro
electronics professor from Venezuela
named Rafael rife Paul would always come
to my office at the start of the
semester this MIT legend president and
then chairman and he would ask me what I
wanted him to teach I would always say
Paul what would you like to teach and he
will always choose six double two
circuits and electronics that's the
first academic subject in electrical
engineering Paul used to say that it was
like learning to play the scales for
musicians is the foundation of
everything he would say but looking back
now I realized what I should have said I
should have asked Paul to teach me how
he managed to lead his life with such
remarkable integrity of course Paul was
profoundly honest he lived by the
highest ethical and moral standards but
integrity I mean went beyond that Paul
was as a person
integrated unified of a piece like an
integrated circuit there was a moral
unity to his whole life a unity of
purpose and values he knew who he was
down to the core that gave him deep
personal confidence in every situation
and he gave everyone else perfect
confidence that he would always do the
right thing and he always did
over time I had the opportunity to ask
Paul for all kinds of advice to be a new
Provost or president here facing your
first big crisis and to have his counsel
it was a gift all of us who came after
him in those jobs felt incredibly
fortunate to know him and they may never
have been a better manager of a
university than Paul Gray his memory on
every issue and his knowledge of the
budget were humbling I must tell you
though that the best advice he ever gave
me about how to handle being president
was don't eat dessert I believe the most
important thing Paul taught by his
example was how to succeed at creating
change at a place like MIT with such a
legacy of excellence persuading people
the things need to change
is a non-trivial exercise but Paul
understood this community so well he
knew how to lead MIT to live up to its
full potential and he also had the
patience for a lot of meetings as a
result more than anyone I can think of
Paul shaped the MIT we know today when
you think of the program some progress
he helped create it's impossible to
imagine MIT without them where will we
be without our undergraduate research
Opportunity Program or Europe
how did first-year students ever manage
without paths no record with MIT even be
MIT if we did not welcome talented
people from every background and did not
turn outward to engage the world
each of these developments represented a
the time serious startling change but
Paul helped our community see that each
of these steps was the bright open path
to possibility I close with one final
Paul Gray lesson as a white male who
arrived when the Institute itself was
overwhelmingly white and male Paul was
not an obvious candidate to lead MIT
into a new era of diversity but as we
will hear today he certainly did
and through that work he proved
something extremely important that in
the life of our community cultural
change and moral growth are possible and
imperative in this complex confusing
time for our nation and therefore for
our community may Paul be as he always
was our guide to inventing a better
future for all
good afternoon I'm Shirley Ann Jackson
the 18th president of Rensselaer
Polytechnic Institute a member of the
MIT classes of 1968 in 1973 and a life
member of the MIT corporation first I
want to thank Paul's wife Priscilla all
of his family and President Rafael
Wright for inviting me to join this
celebration of the life of Paul Gray
today I admired and loved Paul Gray as
did all of us he was someone I turned to
throughout my career whenever I had a
difficult decision to make because I
knew that he would guide me towards the
right end but beyond that I've always
felt an enormous sense of kinship with
Paul because we shared important moments
of leadership together when I was an
undergraduate at MIT I was one of just
two african-american women in my class
it was a lonely chilly experience and
although I was a good student I was not
entirely accepted by my classmates or
even by some of my professors in the
spring of 1968 I was deciding among
graduate schools and I was on the way to
the airport after a visit to the
University of Pennsylvania what I
learned that the Reverend dr. Martin
Luther King jr. had been shot and killed
in Memphis Tennessee inspired by the
courage and sacrifice of dr. King and
others in the civil rights movement I
realized that MIT needed to become a
more welcoming place for
african-americans for women for people
from all backgrounds and origins and
given that its outsized influence in
science and engineering when you change
MIT you change the world
now at the time there were very few
african-american faculty members or
administrators to spearhead such an
effort so a group of like-minded
students and I formed the black Students
Union and we presented a list of demands
to the MIT administration only we called
them proposals now in response MIT
formed the task force on educational
opportunity to address the embedded
issues in its if infinite wisdom MIT
asked Paul Gray who soon became
associate provost to take charge of the
response Paul always said that this was
his first real chance to exercise
leadership of any form at MIT and that's
a quote and he quickly demonstrated that
he was a true leader exactly the right
mature person for a turbulent time he
took what could have been an adversarial
situation and sometimes it was and
instantly identified our shared
objectives and although he was MIT
through and through he immediately
grasped that MIT could and should be
better I was invited to join the task
force on educational opportunity which I
did during my first year of graduate
school here at MIT I had decided that I
needed to remain at MIT for graduate
school because I knew that it was
important to work to change things here
and I felt that I could make a
difference now until that moment so Paul
tells me he had told me I feel like he's
still here Paul had never had the
opportunity before to get to know any
african-americans having grown up in an
all-white community gone to a tall white
high school and served in an all-white
unit of the army but importantly he was
an empathetic person who could always
pull something
from inside himself to find common
ground with the person sitting across
from him as a teenager with an intense
interest in amateur radio and
electronics he had felt like an outsider
he had some insight therefore into how
difficult that could be so he was ready
to listen to learn and to act thanks to
Paul the Task Force on educational
opportunity spurred a breathtaking
change at MIT
until then MIT had not done much
recruiting of any kind for students but
why would it it was MIT after all but
under Paul's leadership MIT hired an
assistant director of admissions who was
african-american for the first time the
Institute developed special recruiting
materials and a stronger financial aid
package and began visiting predominantly
african-american high schools
saying to the most talented young men
and women there we want you at MIT Paul
also had the wisdom to send the black
Students Union students including me on
as many of these recruiting trips as we
could manage amidst our studies to prove
to African American high schoolers that
MIT was indeed a realistic possibility
we had convinced Paul that merely
bringing underrepresented minorities to
MIT was not enough because some of the
high schools did not offer advanced
Science and Mathematics so they would be
starting in what I had called an Olympic
level race from meters behind they
needed an introduction to the rigorous
coursework of MIT and to become
confident that they could succeed here
so the task force also initiated project
interphase which continues to this day
project interphase was an intense
six-week summer program for incoming
freshmen who needed it with classes in
physics and precalculus among other
subjects and a wonderful introduction to
the MIT culture
I taught physics and interphase and
although I was still the graduate
student I was asked to run the physics
program in its second year as you can
imagine these were radical changes for
MIT in the late 1960s
Paul was criticized initially by some
faculty members who thought that he was
lowering the quality of the student body
and some of my peers called via
collaborationist for working so closely
with the white administration now Paul
was even addressed in a derogatory and
profane fashion by some very angry
african-american students on one
occasion but Paul was always cool-headed
even them in the most heated times and
he was tough when he knew he was right
the students Pete Paul helped to bring
to MIT thrived and proved not just to
MIT but to the nation that brilliance
and science and engineering is not the
province of any single background
ethnicity or place of origin that
experience of working with Paul taught
me first what leadership is he also
taught me that I was leader and it led
to many other opportunities for me
throughout my life and career for which
I am immensely grateful Paul also taught
me by example that leadership requires
toughness tenacity and importantly a
willingness to be a bit of a
collaborationist in other words to
listen to others to identify points of
intersection and to work to turn
opponents into supporters Paul as all of
you know went on to become Chancellor
creating the first formal plan to
increase the presence of women and
minorities among the faculty as well as
the student body he then became the
fourteenth president of MIT and later
the chair of the MIT corporation and as
you have heard Paul changed the
experience and many important ways
throughout his career including
modernizing the electrical engineering
curriculum for the age of semiconductors
in the early 1960s and championing of
radical idea that president rife
referenced the undergraduate research
opportunities program in the late 1960s
at the behest of and in collaboration
with Margaret MacVicar who also happened
to be my physics tutor early in my
career in the women's dorm importantly
Paul and Priscilla as partners worked to
make MIT a more welcoming place in
myriad ways for everyone here especially
the students Paul always cited
increasing the diversity of MIT as his
most important accomplishment and as you
know when he arrived as an undergraduate
fewer than one in 50 MIT under students
was a woman or an underrepresented
minority and by the end of his tenure as
president in 1990 women were more than
30 percent of the incoming classes and
underrepresented minorities 14 percent
now Paul truly changed the world as an
educational innovator and by paving the
way for the rest of us who continue to
work to bring the full complement of
young talent into science and
engineering but it was not just the
institutional Paul Gray but the personal
Paul Bray who was so important in my
life he was a sounding board mentor
supporter and friend throughout my
career we often talked about the
importance of education for our national
well-being especially in science and
engineering and about pedagogical
innovation importantly at crucial points
of decision and opportunity in my life I
could always turn to Paul and did for
advice and counsel moreover he was my
greatest
and personal advocate for important
positions including the chairmanship of
the US Nuclear Regulatory Commission and
the presidency of Rensselaer Polytechnic
Institute in fact when I was developing
the Rensselaer plan our strategic
blueprint Paul came to the University to
help to explain to our Board of Trustees
the crucial linkage of research and
teaching in educating young people in
science and engineering and because of
that it was a great honor to have Paul
write the foreword to a book that was a
retrospective of my first 10 years as
president of Rensselaer so it was a
great privilege to have shared a
particular period in history with Paul
Gray and to have made something happen
alongside him and later on my own with
his support and friendship it was a
privilege in fact just to have known him
Paul was kind he was sensible he had
moral courage and he grew into a dear
friend and I will always cherish the
long talks and walks we had when my
husband Morris and I would visit Paul
and Priscilla in Rhode Island often in
the winter and our hunts for the
crustaceans that Priscilla loved so much
I'm so grateful to Paul Gray for
teaching me so much and for his
incredible grace I will miss him for the
rest of my life I thank all of you for
allowing me to honor this great man
Priscilla and members of the gray family
Rafael and members of the MIT community
distinguished guests ladies and
gentlemen
I'm Victor Fong I'm from Hong Kong I am
from MIT class of 66 and Paul Gray was
my thesis advisor for my master's thesis
I can't tell you what a great honor and
privilege it is for me to speak at this
service for an MIT legend whose life and
humanity touched all of us
Paul Grey's belief in diversity and
inclusion has borne out by Shirley
Jackson's brilliant achievements also
benefited me when I was a 20 year old
MIT student from Hong Kong indeed some
50 years ago Paul wrote me a letter that
has since been a guiding light for my
entire career
it was 1966 and I was doing a thesis for
my masters in electrical engineering in
fact I was blessed to be the last thesis
student professor gray mentored before
going full-time into administration it
was most gracious of him to take me on
as he was already extremely busy
as associate dean for student affairs
Paul said a cyan hour every week out of
his very busy schedule and if my memory
serves me correctly it was 4:00 p.m.
every Thursday for me to come to his
office so that he could guide and review
my progress I still remember his office
was on the fourth door on the beginning
of the infinite corridor as you go in
and seventy-seven myself I must confess
I was not always punctual nor was my
attendance entirely reliable I think I
might have missed one or two times I was
doing a co-op program at general radio
during the day and then working on my
thesis at night
but keeping a dean waiting was not the
smartest thing that I've ever done the
thesis was about computer-aided design
of Schmitt trigger circuits very
technical in fact I read the thesis
again recently and I couldn't believe
that was what I wrote when I finish Paul
wrote me a five-page letter the gist was
based on the quality and content of the
work in your thesis
I'm giving you an A but I want you to
know that I'm giving you this a
reluctantly the way you plan and
structure your work and your interaction
with me do not deserve any of course I
told my parents in Hong Kong only about
the grade I didn't dare tell them about
the letter but as I started my career
Paul's treasure letter gave me much food
for thought I have reread it many many
times over the years Paul really
impressed upon me that having the bright
idea is not enough you've got to have
the discipline to put those ideas into a
context where they can be effective if
you wish to end up with a final piece or
a final product that is truly excellent
you have got to execute properly I'm
sure each and every one of you here
today have been touched by this
wonderful individual at some point in
your careers and in his own very special
way that is not all that I've learned
from Paul in him I found a man whose
values resonate deeply with those of my
own family commitment loyalty fairness
and I have just indicated frankness Paul
also care passionately that technical
technological change should be a force
for good in communities and societies
globally
and ethos which continues to inspire
drive a room family company lien fronted
a long ago and one opposed many visits
to Hong Kong as MIT president he asked
if I would consider making a meaningful
donation to this Institute I explained
that I couldn't at the time because I
was putting every cent I had into a bio
of the family company but I made a
commitment that when I did have the
means I would be back imagine then what
a joy it was to see porn priscila at
last year's ceremony announcing mi t--'s
new makerspace at the Metropolitan
warehouse which my brother William and I
are honored to support it was the last
time I saw poor I saw one appalled to
know that the seed he planted years ago
had ripened for reasons that include my
lifelong gratitude to him and to MIT
when he became my mentor
Paul was only 34 years old younger than
my children are today yet the serious
proper man always seemed wiser than his
years just as he was years ahead of his
time
Paul was truly the master who appeared
when the student was ready he helped me
formulate my life and what to make of it
for sure I shall be keeping that letter
of his safely under lock and key for
future generations of my family thank
you
good afternoon my name is Jim Taylor I
sometimes respond to the description of
the younger brother that Paul never had
and the older brother that Virginia
never had in 1965 I was a senior at MIT
and looking for a way to finance
graduate school and avoid the Vietnam
War providentially ken Wadley then Dean
of Student Affairs was bringing on board
a new associate dean and needed a grunt
to do some work in the with respect to
the freshmen curriculum Paul Gray and
untenured professor of Electrical
Engineering became that associate dean
and I was the grunt between us over the
next 18 years we did some over the next
18 months we did some work around the
freshmen program which resulted to some
changes but more importantly we
established a lifelong friendship that
can never be replaced Paul became my
role model now role model can take many
forms and I've come to believe that
there are at least four elements to
being a role model I call them the four
FS faith fitness family and profession
and the search for somebody that
embodies all of those very difficult
many people never find that but I was
fortunate enough and to both find it and
recognize it early on
so Paul became the standard by which
I've measured much of the remainder of
my life I won't say a lot about the
professional element Paul's 47 years at
MIT the what he called this special
place has been well-documented will be
well described by other people but I
would like to just talk quickly about
the project that we worked on together
because it was actually the first thing
that Paul did in an administrative
capacity to benefit MIT through the mid
60s
the freshman curriculum was absolutely
identical for all freshmen chemistry
physics math humanities absolutely the
same courses taught in the same way
regardless of the high school student
preparation a regardless of academic
intention and Paul was asked the
question is that the way it ought to be
so we did some studies on that we had
some hypotheses to test for example I
call these intuitively obvious I'm not
sure why we had to analyze them but for
example if a student in high school had
had calculus would they do better in
calculus and physics at MIT than if they
hadn't had calculus that seemed pretty
obvious but we needed to analyze that
bring some data to bear on it come up
with some conclusions so we had a lot of
data on freshmen classes and we had
state-of-the-art computing the
state-of-the-art computing in 1965 was
an IBM 1402 and an IBM 84 it's unlikely
that most of you know what those numbers
be but it's actually a punch card reader
and a card sorter that's what we use
that is what we use for computing
support needless to say our analytical
work
verify that there should be some changes
in the freshmen program it needn't be
monolithic and totally structured the
same way for all students and as a
result of that MIT implemented some
variations in chemistry physics
especially physics and math and
permitted students to take variations
depending on their academic interests
and future what I learned from that was
not not only the what I would call
almost the obvious conclusions but more
importantly the way Paul approached
complex problems his clarity of thought
was incredible his integrity his mutual
respect for others including his grunt
just came through in that project
instead set standards from our own
professional career I mentioned the
faith element briefly Paul didn't talk
much about his faith he simply lived it
he was a longtime member at Hancock
Church in Lexington or Priscilla still
worships they were active in a small
group Bible study for more than 50 years
they traveled together socialized but
mostly studied the Bible I marveled at
how he served in key positions in key
committees at his church while
fulfilling demanding jobs at MIT fitness
and its companion food represented a
wide area for Paul and me to explore
together
we played squash intensely and I learned
not to take control of the tea when Paul
was behind me
I learned the significance of the phrase
coming around Paul taught me to drink my
coffee black how to enjoy butter in
every nook and cranny of English muffinz
we loved Priscilla's lobster boils
lasagna and her sticky buns
we shared Thanksgiving dinners in the
president's house we ate tex-mex
in Corpus Christi where our son
Paul's namesake was born more than 40
years ago we suffered the same sweet
tooth for cookies and ice cream when I
took up running
Paul tried to convince me that rice at
royal East was an acceptable form of
carb loading before the Boston Marathon
he was wrong in our early days we hiked
the White Mountains with Virginia and
amy and in recent years we walked slowly
around Walden Pond but for me Paul's
most significant impact was through his
dedication to his family when you got to
know Paul you got the whole family his
parents sent him off from Livingston New
Jersey to MIT and were always a bit
puzzled as to why he never left and
shortly after I started working for Paul
I met Priscilla his partner in all
things Virginia was a precocious
eight-year-old pushing the boundaries
amy was a fine arts talent especially
creative in fabric and textiles
Andrew was Paul's buddy trying out new
things including each other's patience
and Louise was then and then on the pixi
the center of impish fun our lives have
intertwined ever since as eyewitness
family life for the grace it followed a
few simple principles spend time
together
be serious have fun be deliberate about
creating memories celebrate together
grieve together never compromised her
integrity easy to say hard to put into
practice and it does sound nearly
perfect but I'll admit I had to do a
little bit of fine-tuning I had to
rescue his children from the monotony of
Mozart by introducing them to Herb
Alpert and the Tijuana brass you'll hear
a lot about Paul's legacy today but for
me it's pretty personal it sustains me
in the areas of faith fitness family and
profession I'd like to think that I'm a
better person for having traveled in
Paul's wake and hope that's been passed
down to some degree to my children and
grandchildren but multiply that by
thousands I daresay nearly everybody
here we've all woven
a third of Paul gray into our lives
that's his lasting legacy a year ago in
one of my visits to see Priscilla and
Paul he wanted to make a special
breakfast on the day I was leaving to
return home he has the night before what
I'd like and I said I really liked the
omelets he made in Little Compton with
Swiss cheese and fresh chives that
struck him is doable so the next morning
after about an hour of scurrying around
in the kitchen he proudly presented
breakfast
delicious blueberry pancakes it was such
a touching moment equal parts sweet and
sad I'm miss Paul
[Music]
[Applause]
it was my privilege 26 years ago to
award you your bachelor's degree and 25
years ago your master's degree
it was soon recognised that your first
straight performance as a teacher was
matched by first-rate talent as an
administrator and you were quickly
co-opted from one administrative job
after another in fact you hardly had the
opportunity to arm the chair in one post
before you were drafted for another
it's very nice to have so many people
from so many institutions and so many
old friends who have come back today to
participate in this celebration I got to
know Paul Gray when I was beginning
graduate school but we really became
close when I became his Provost I first
met him through his deep involvement in
undergraduate education at MIT he was a
great friend a great colleague but also
a very great teacher for me
I got involved as an athlete as a
swimmer as a rower as a sailor and I
would often see him and I would invite
him to our competitions and he would
come and I remember he and Priscilla
coming into swimming meet and just
sitting down and staying for the whole
time he was a quietly very brave
tenacious man loving and kind and gentle
and very focused and always very engaged
he loved being around experts and taking
advice from experts and learning from
experts and sharing with experts he was
the father who took us hiking biking
swimming sailing skating he's the one
who ran behind us when we were learning
to ride our bikes until we could do it
on our own
there were no training wheels you just
figured it out
[Music]
Paul began his MIT life as a freshman
pole came to imagine 1950 so that's
almost 70 years has just simply
remarkable
I can't think of anybody else who gave
so much of his life is sure so much of
his life with this Institute he's a very
down-to-earth individual very
straightforward man but very caring he
did so much for him I teared he did a
loyal e he did it morning noon at night
he's so devoted to this place and to the
students in such a genuine way he was
never in it for himself he was always in
it for MIT
some years ago in a commencement in the
rain a father was heard to say after the
soaking I've taken for the last four
years who minds a little rain
but I have to say this is something else
in the competitive sport of diving the
various dives are ranked according to
the degree of difficulty when the
performances of different divers are
equal the diver who chooses to dive with
the highest degree of difficulty wins
now by that measure alone you here today
or Winterson you have chosen and
successfully negotiated a collegiate
education having what may be the
nation's highest degree of difficulty
[Applause]
and we always called it this special
place I think for him it really was a
special place and a kind of home unlike
he'd ever had before because it
satisfied him intellectually and it
satisfied him I think emotionally and
when he was able to connect his own
family to it then I think that that was
sort of a full-circle MIT is best known
for the scientists and engineers what
studied there he was at MIT at a time
when engineering changed completely from
largely empirical practice of making
things and making them work to a
situation where science and
understanding fundamentals affected the
design and the implementation of so many
systems this very gentle quiet fierce
man I know had to do battle to get
Whitehead Institute established before
terribly suspicious and you know frankly
he wasn't sure what it would be
nobody was it was an experiment and he
took the risk
MIT in the biomedical Enterprise in
Kendall Square is unrivaled anywhere in
the world and so I do credit Paul with
setting us out in that direction so the
Whitehead we now have the broad and the
Reagan the Koch Institute any number of
expressions of the power of biology to
transform our world when I came to MIT
which was in 1965 I think maybe two or
three percent of the students were women
fewer than that on the faculty it was
very much a male institution he was
tremendously committed to diversity
increasing the representation in the
faculty in a student body of women and
of minorities the number of entering
african-american students at MIT went
from about three to five per year to 57
to this day I mean we're just very proud
of that momentum Apple brought to the
table on this issue MIT has a
responsibility to itself and to the
nation to be open and indeed to reach
out to the most talented and promising
people regardless of race or sex
none of us created all the bias around
us but we certainly inherit it and what
I love about president Grey is that he
stepped right into that and as soon as
he saw it and understood it he decided
to actually do something about it
during his inauguration what he wanted
as the walking in music was Aaron
Copland's fanfare for the common man and
that was him you know
[Music]
he always was in touch with his very
modest beginnings in a blue-collar
family where you know the economy was a
challenge
one of his fraternity brothers while he
was at MIT as a sophomore was dating a
woman at Wheaton College where my mother
was a freshman they introduced my
parents on what turned out to be a
rather successful blind date it was very
cold and they're walking across the
bridge and my mother doesn't have any
gloves and my father said I've got a
pair of gloves why don't we do this I'll
wear the left one you wear the right one
and we'll hold hands to keep the middle
ones warm and they walked across the
bridge and they walked off into the
future that was the first day of their
relationship I thought well that's
that's pretty good for a nerd from New
Jersey a very clever use of a pair of
gloves to win the girl's heart
[Music]
it was the big blizzard of 78 and no
cars were allowed on the road you know
for a week but my tea was not going to
shut down so we started this bus line
and one of my favorite pictures of Paul
Gray is with his big wolf skin or beaver
skin hat you know we're like a Russian
hat
out in the parking lot at MIT where the
buses came in directing traffic I mean
he was very much hands-on he looks
incredibly happy actually in the picture
he was just doing what he could do I
think and having fun doing it
I think he had a lot of joy and what he
did
he was a real proponent of the
undergraduate research opportunities
program Europe it was dramatically
successful and found a way for
undergraduates to interact with the
faculty in their research project this
would be a way in which students could
for the first time perhaps in her years
at MIT come to terms with an unsolved
real problem something where they could
make a genuine contribution that became
an integral part of how MIT educate
students so it was a huge thing for us
when he finished up all the
administrative and leadership roles they
had MIT he went back to the classroom he
loved being in the classroom you turned
the crank on a 3 by 3 matrix and solve
for the node voltages he sub B he sub C
and E sub D it was an absolutely
excellent teacher clarity complete
concern with the students understanding
very much enjoyed being in their company
professor gray was my academic advisor
when I was an undergrad here at MIT and
I remember he was a really warm very
friendly giving advisor at first maybe
you would think it might be a little
intimidating having your advisors would
be the extra president of MIT but that
turned out not to be the case at all
professor gray was extremely
down-to-earth
he really understood technological
education and what a a technological
research university is really about and
how precious it is
[Music]
one of the many involvement that the
greys had with students whether these
senior dinners we invited the whole
class to dinner 60 or 70 at a time all
of us at MIT we just celebrate the
opportunities to be with those students
they are so special
every semester on registration day we
would meet with him and then that
evening all of us all of his advisers
would go out to dinner with him always
at the Royal East if you can imagine
there was sort of a a big table usually
in the back of the restaurant all filled
with I'd say maybe about ten or so
advisees yours is the obligation to help
heal this society where healing is
required to help strengthen the nation's
we're strengthening is required and to
help bring harmony among the nations of
this world wherever discord obtains if
you have ever seen Paul's official
presidential portrait it is a portrait
of Paul in Priscilla he was the first
person to have his spouse in the picture
right and I think that for him that was
a measure of his devotion for her his
appreciation for all the things that my
mother may have sacrificed in order to
help him have the roles and the
opportunities that he had and all the
ways in which she supported him I think
that that was his way of saying you know
I wouldn't have been able to do this
without Priscilla was extraordinary to
watch them together how they work
together how they supported each other
they both had a twinkle in their eye
they were kind of pinging at you
just to know that there was someone sort
of watching over us making sure that
things generally are probably gonna be
okay for us so I really appreciated that
very much he is a man of exceptional
integrity the humanists of the van and
of Priscilla was so essential to the
kind of leadership he provided at MIT he
cared about people
a person with tremendous integrity a
person with tremendous wisdom thoughtful
call an extraordinarily forceful person
but also with a surprisingly gentle
personality he was good at listening he
was good at negotiating and meeting
people part way and he was good at
imagining what might be possible if this
shifted or that changed or we could move
forward together in this direction as
you undertake this next stage in your
lives I wish for you a life that is rich
in opportunities to stretch your talents
your interests your imagination and your
vision of this small planet as a
beautiful oasis generating peace and as
you depart from this special place I
wish you Godspeed
[Music]
you
that was a remarkable remarkable tribute
I'm Susan Hockfield and I served as the
16th president of MIT and it is a very
great but a very sad privilege to offer
a few words in celebration of the 14th
president of MIT Paul E gray I first met
Paul Gray during my initial introduction
to MIT Paul served as a member of the
presidential search committee that
brought me to the Institute even among
the truly impressive and distinguished
committee members Paul by any measure
held the deepest knowledge and the
greatest breadth of understanding of MIT
however even among that group with that
task at hand he demonstrated one of his
core characteristics doing far more
listening than speaking and those
interviews and first conversations I
came to understand that Paul's patience
as a listener captured the essential
trait of the greatest teachers a
remarkable skill in leading us his
students to discover the answers
ourselves when I arrived on campus as
the Institute's newly minted president
Paul became my first and most essential
guide to MIT his love of the place of
the people and of our mission shone
brightly and all he said and all he did
as my family joined our new community he
and his beloved Priscilla warmly adopted
us giving Tom Elizabeth and me a
profoundly appreciated sense of being at
home a part of me has always and will
always see MIT through Paul's eyes and
through Priscilla's eyes to the two of
them inseparably led MIT in head hand
and heart Paul as we've heard again and
again transformed the Institute in a
host of important ways
looking through a particular set of
lenses one can see how it was he who
paved the path that brought me to MIT as
the Institute's first woman and first
biologist to serve as president as
president Jackson has described so
beautifully
Paul considered his work expanding
opportunities for women and minorities
to be his most important contribution
he understood deeply that for MIT to
serve the nation and the world most
effectively we needed to bring more of
the most talented people to our campus
no matter their gender or phenotype he
championed admitting more women and
minority students and bringing greater
diversity to our faculty and staff not
just in words but also in deeds the
number of women's students and faculty
grew and he appointed women to important
roles margaret mcvickers leadership of
the paradigm breaking undergraduate
research opportunities program Europe
transformed a core tenant of the
undergraduate experience through Europe
we invite our students to move beyond
receiving knowledge in our classrooms to
discovering knowledge in our
laboratories when Paul arrived as an
undergraduate his class included fewer
than 2% women when I arrived as mi t--'s
president over 45% of the entering
freshmen were women Paul had primed the
Institute for a woman president in many
critically important ways Paul
accelerated mi t--'s rise to world-class
excellence in biology and fostered the
remarkable development of the Kendall
square innovation cluster now you might
well accuse me of seeing the world
through biology tinted glasses but 20/20
hindsight shows clearly that Paul
recognized early on the growing
importance and long-range possibilities
of the molecular biology revolution the
biology department had adopted this Rev
Ellucian airy way of studying the level
living world with a kind of monomania
propelling the institute to national and
international leadership paul actively
fostered the department's many offshoots
the Center for cancer research was
launched when Paul was Chancellor and as
president he navigated the complex and
sometimes vexed discussions that led to
the establishment of the Whitehead
Institute for biomedical research in the
words of Institute professor Philip
sharp Paul made the Whitehead happen
Paul provided a new building of which
there were not many during his
presidency for the biology department
and perhaps more significantly for EM I
t's definition of ourselves he supported
the adoption of the biology requirement
for all undergraduates setting biology
on equal footing among em I t's
canonical triumvirate of physics math
and chemistry taken together Paul set
conditions in place for the biological
biomedical biotech explosion at MIT and
in Kendall Square and in this way too he
primed the Institute for its first
biologist president always the teacher
Paul orchestrated a magnificent gift to
me in my first months on campus he
gathered his class of 54 colleagues and
their newly donned Cardinal jackets to
meet me
our dinner together taught me more about
the tradition devotion and pride carried
by MIT alumni than any abstract
description could have done as the adage
about teaching goes he didn't tell me he
showed me many who attended that dinner
are here with us this afternoon and I
would say again what I said that evening
thank you Paul for bringing us together
in support of mi t--'s core values the
pursuit of truth
meritocracy personal integrity and
service to others and let me say again
for showing us rather than telling us
these core values we thank you Paul
I am Gerald Wilson and I served as dean
of engineering while Paul was president
each of us have memories of our
interaction with Paul Gray and how he
impacted our lives in our experience at
MIT I first saw Paul when he was a
teaching assistant in a junior year
subject I was taking he was
demonstrating electromechanical
principles on a rotating machine in a
building three lecture hall he was an
early influence in the Department of
Electrical Engineering
when electronics was transitioning from
vacuum tube devices to semiconductor
devices he co-authored four of the seven
texts which were some of the earliest
teaching tools that enabled that
transition later after he was president
he lectured a sophomore electronic
subject I remember his demonstrating
negative feedback in a circuit and is
pointing out that negative feedback if
you was carefully could be a positive
factor in social situations as well his
style
whether teaching in a formal classroom
lecture or explaining his views on some
administrative manner was characterized
as you heard by careful methodical and
thoughtful descriptions he was always
approachable and receptive of questions
even in a lecture hall with 200 students
the environment he engendered was one of
sharing what he knew with many students
engaging him after lecture to ask
questions he was a warm dedicated and
effective teacher early on Paul was
looked to for his wisdom and advice his
careful thoughtful and earnest approach
to a question
was very often reflected in his facial
expression you could see his effort to
provide a thoughtful response to your
question even in casual conversation
during the Vietnam War era there was
much protesting and anger among our
students and our faculty we had an AWOL
soldier ensconced in the Student Center
300 state and city police marched down
Massachusetts Avenue in phallin's to
confront students blocking employees in
the instrumentation laboratory students
occupied the president's office
throughout Paul was often a calming
influence during this period seeking the
best result for those involved he
focused on allowing protest without
allowing it to destroy the institution
he was always approachable he seemed to
remember everyone he had met by name
whether a student a research or support
staff or a faculty member he encouraged
people to call him Paul putting aside
titles and that is how he was addressed
by many a measure how of how he was
viewed and trusted by the community and
with that he engendered and nourished a
sense of community that most everyone
felt a sense of belonging to a place
that strived for excellence a place you
could trust he was clearly a leader and
behaved as one for whom the institution
was deserving of only his best he would
carefully and promptly consider a
proposal brought before him once he had
made a decision to embrace an idea
brought by others he became their
champion
whether it was Europe to embrace our
undergraduates involvement in research a
new building for a department or school
a microelectronic center a manufacturing
initiative
a project to bring computers into the
hands of students and faculty
establishing an Institute for Biological
research in the face of considerable
concern and controversy on the part of
faculty once he was convinced that it
had to be done he put his own effort
into it by helping to develop a strategy
for for a meeting with prospective
donors he was so much more than the
approving executive he was a hands-on
supporter and builder of the initiative
one time I had won his support for an
initiative that was going to require 18
million dollars in funding months later
I had to return to inform him that the
cost was to double I had expected a
disappointed reaction that's at least
and a question of whether we should
proceed
instead he characterized it as
unfortunate but then went on to help me
identify ways that could still make it
happen
no recrimination just support and help
and creatively solving the problem I
always felt that he had my back
Paul had a consistent and deep concern
for the experience that MIT provided for
our undergraduate students with
Priscilla's strong involvement he
addressed significant issues that
affected the undergraduate environment
early on as you've heard he became
concerned that there were so few women
and mi t--'s gradual under undergraduate
population he learned that the cause in
part was a lack of adequate housing for
women women's and missions were
restricted due to the limited space of a
women's dormitory over in Boston he took
action and removed that restriction and
with a gift from Helen McCormack
provided significant in larger dormitory
space for women Paul also addressed mi
t--'s lack of a strong minority content
and the undergraduate class before he
was the president he aggressively worked
with others to change our approach by
seeking out and attracting minorities
not just waiting for them to apply
changing our environment in this regard
had its difficulties
we had to learn how to identify students
who could succeed here
but Paul persevered and stuck to his
core beliefs that we could make MIT a
place or a diverse student body could
succeed by the time he completed his
presidency there was a sea change in the
environment was if Nick Utley more
minority and women undergraduates
he drove MIT to be a welcoming and
successful place for a diverse
undergraduate student body with
Priscilla they made MIT a more welcoming
environment for our undergraduates they
held dinners at grey house for the
entire senior class each year hosting
seventy or more students at a time
he and Priscilla engendered a welcoming
spirit and tone that permeated the place
in ways that continue to have an ever
lasting effect on the entire community
how does one summarize the life of a man
who with so much dedication did so much
for this institution in that effort I
was reminded of the spirit of a verse
that is often used in a Jewish memorial
service for the creative tivity quality
and Karen's teaching we remember him for
his leadership guidance and calming
influence in times of strife we remember
him for strengthening our sense of
community for making MIT a place of
trust and honesty we remember him for
his encouragement support and
championship for the work of others we
remember him for his friendship we
remember him
for his commitment concern for and
dedication to the environment for our
students we remember him for his
leadership drive and commitment for
attracting more women and minority
students and to assuring that they
concede succeed here we remember him for
all of his efforts and commitment to MIT
to which he's only so fondly referred to
as this special place we remember him
today we gather to honor and celebrate
my dad and I thank all of you for being
here this event means so much to my
mother and the gray family on a point of
perspective I would like to point out
however that this is more than a
celebration of a life well-lived if we
are to honor my father and what he meant
to this institution we must also
recognize what this institution meant to
him I think that today we gather to
celebrate MIT as well we've heard it
several times today my dad called MIT
this special place I think that all of
us here today are blessed in some
special precious way whether you teach
learn research administrate clean
maintain or facilitate the workings of
the school and some non-academic way or
just love someone who does or did I
think that it's hard not to be touched
by the power and promise of MIT I grew
up in a house where we did not know the
position of the Red Sox in the AL East
standings I did not know what the
Stanley Cup was until the globe
published that iconic photograph of
Bobby Orr
parallel to the ice but I did know who
had won the Nobel Prizes and what
schools they worked at hmm
shortly after dad's passing with my cell
phone dink
you know those noises alert noises with
the news alert that dr. Rainer Weiss had
won this year's Prize in Physics along
with two of his colleagues from another
school that shall not be named I had to
smile this would have pleased dad so
much if Dad were alive and we were in an
earlier better day the race would have
been on to see if I get the news to him
before he heard of course I would have
lost that race MIT always had better
communications technology I believe that
a big part of what made MIT so special
for my dad was that it was the land of
his heroes for the great kids or the
Corps for as we like to call ourselves
this aspect of my dad's life was
completely transparent and open these
incredible people were also the Titans
in our lives I visited doc Edgerton in
his lab we saw her image tonight and I
think I've heard her name mentioned at
least three times tonight but I used to
spend weekends doing chores with dr.
Margaret MacVicar on her farm and in
high school I spoke with dr. Jerry
Wiesner
when I waited for dad in the suite of
offices that they shared almost every
day and perhaps most importantly our big
brother Jim tail or class 65 taught us
kids the Texas two-step when my family
was last all together we gathered a
hancock church and remembrance of dad on
that day dr. rife flew in from welcoming
his third grandchild to this world to
make sure that he was there to sit with
my mother dr. Jackson another touchstone
in the tapestry of my father's life was
also there from great distance to be
with my mother and of course Jim Taylor
who had flown in upon my dad's passing
to spend three days when my mother had
returned it would be impossible to
adequately express the gratitude of my
family for all of you and the countless
colleagues friends and students we are
profoundly grateful for all that you
have done for my dad both in life and in
death MIT truly is this special place
it's it's people that make it so as I
prepare to speak today I thought about
different approaches to these comments
ultimately the most visceral lesson of
these past few months was what a
humbling experience it has been humbling
to see dad go humbling to see him make
it okay for us
humbling to realize that my thinking
that the inevitable cannot be escaped
and that I was okay with all of this was
mere arrogance humbling to realize they
don't have any wisdom except to recommit
to being the best father husband brother
son colleague and school guy I can be
with your forbearance I would like to
share what I presented a Hancock Church
a couple months ago it best contains
what I want to tell you about my dad and
I think my mom liked it so we're gonna
do it again I once asked my dad what the
single most important decision of his
career at MIT was and as dr. Wilson just
shared with us when asked that question
he said the decision to move the women
on to campus here at MIT and get rid of
that dorm was the turning point for this
school and that closing that dorm set
MIT on its path to what it was to become
such a simple thing such a powerful
thing as a kid I learned to love curry
at the Mukherjee's and tempura at the Yi
wasis at MIT events dinners hosted a
home my mother and the all-important
wonderful memorable Thanksgivings with
dads advisees we met people from all
across America and all around the world
mom and dad took us to live in northern
Wales and we toured Europe when dad had
a break my parents came back from MIT
trips to places like India II
Mexico China Japan and shared the wonder
of what they had seen and learned the
point I would like to make is that my
parents work diligently and
intentionally to expose us to a world
that was as big as MIT it was clear to
us that they valued diversity in all its
forms and that engaging with and
learning from the broadest possible
group of people was something to be
treasured and valued as a source of
profound strength as I matured whether
it was because I was old enough to hear
certain stories or whether because I
started paying attention and linking
things up that we did not really talk
about as a family I came to understand
that based on the context and the value
system that my dad was raised in he
would have seemed a very unlikely
champion of diversity after my kids were
born I decided that I need to ask my dad
about this
how had his values in this regard varied
so widely from what he knew as a child
while splitting wood down at Little
Compton with him I tried to nicely frame
my central question which boiled down to
hey Dad how come you didn't turn out to
be a bigot
so I asked and he put down the mall took
off his gloves wiped his brow and he
thought he told me well I guess it just
never made any sense to me
he put his gloves back on and we went
back to work
such a simple thing such a powerful
thing as a dyslexic kid that did not
learn to read until the good folks at
the Carroll school taught me to
mainstream standardized academic success
was a stranger to me
I failed kindergarten not an easy thing
to do
I got bounced out of chemistry as a
junior in high school because the whole
mold thing completely eluded me and I
only graduated from high school because
Rose Maurice our man of Hancock Church
intensively tutored me in German and
helped me eke out a 60 point to 5%
average for the year it was not really
until college and more particularly
graduate school where I was able to play
to my strengths that I experienced solid
academic success and truly enjoyed
school now duck supposed that with my
dad clearly one of the best and most
talented minds that many of us will know
in our lifetimes he could have crushed
me with a simple ill-chosen word he
never did to be clear there were no free
passes in the gray house all report
cards were reviewed with dad and
discussed in detail but dad always
threaded that needle between exhorting
me to do my best and holding me
accountable while building my confidence
and honoring my success in the face of
adversity I am profoundly grateful for
that I can remember MIT events and
gatherings where well-intentioned people
would ask me what I was going to study
when I went to MIT
mit was clearly not on my life choice
menu nor did it align with my strengths
and interests
I remember one
particularly robust grilling by an
alumni of my father's generation who
clearly thought that the son of Paul
Gray must be a regular chip off the old
block and ready to take MIT by storm as
this gentleman talked out of the corner
of my eye I saw my dad and as I focused
on him he gave me his I am proud of you
smile such a simple thing such a
powerful thing dad was often asked for
advice at how to be successful his
response was consistent he would suggest
that you need to find what interested to
you most and commit yourself to it fully
and the rest would take care of itself
at a very real level this was extremely
uncomfortable advice wouldn't it be
easier if there were just a school to
attend a few courses to take or books to
read dad's advice was premise taun
self-awareness thinking for yourself as
well as being accountable to yourself my
dad spent with the exception of his
service with the army of which he was
extremely proud his entire career at MIT
I don't know if you all know this about
him but he never wrote a resume
I once asked him to look at her resume
and I'd written and he said I really
don't know much about that you have to
ask someone else
he served MIT with devotion and passion
and was blessed with the opportunity to
leave his mark on the institution at
every step of his career clearly each
day of his life
my dad relentlessly lived the advice he
so often gave such a simple thing such a
powerful thing
oddly in thinking about all the times I
heard him asked about success I never
heard anyone ask him for advice on how
to be happy
of course I believed he would have given
essentially the same answer but just
extended the scope to include a spouse
and all the family love and power that
arises from and around the union of two
people I believe that if asked all the
core four would tell you that my
father's devotion to my mother and of
course hers to him has provided the
foundation in the framework for the
lives that we and our kids live today a
Father's love such a simple thing such a
powerful thing thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you
[Laughter]
[Music]
my name is Larry back ow class of 72 and
like many of the people in this room I
was a student of Paul's however it was
not in course 6 rather Paul helped to
teach me how to be a university
president shortly after I was named
president of Tufts Paul told me what my
new life would be like running a
research university he said was like
trying to drive an 18-wheeler down an
icy hilly mountain road with multiple
hairpin turns no guardrails and
thousand-foot drop offs and if that
wasn't hard enough faculty have their
hands on the wheel students have their
foot on the accelerator and alumni have
their foot on the brake and you are
responsible for the outcome Paul had a
pithy way of making his point I was to
receive all sorts of good advice from
him as I prepared to leave the
comfortable surroundings of MIT for the
wilds of Medford before you meet with
anyone ask yourself whose job are you
doing now very good advice for a
university president right
surely in Susan one of Paul's favorites
he used to say you know you need to Pat
people 10 times on the back for every
time you kick them in the rear nothing
succeeds like a successor very true
if you can't get your work done in 24
hours in a day start working nights and
Adele's favorite and Priscilla she's
shot sorry she can't be here with me
today but her absolute favorite on any
given night you will have four or five
invitations so you're going to be
disappointing three or four different
people or groups my advice to you at
least one night a week disappoint all of
them I could go on David Riesman the
Harvard sociologist and student of
higher education used to say that
university presidents become the living
walking logos of their institutions in
reflecting upon this statement I don't
think any president of any institution
ever represented the values of the place
better than Paul did here Paul Gray was
MIT he was incredibly smart but also
incredibly modest he was tough but
caring he took his work seriously but
never himself he was comfortable
greeting heads of state but
fundamentally he was blue-collar
he was also refreshingly unpretentious
what other college president adopted as
their email address a character from a
Walt Kelly comic strip Pogo at mit.edu
as Paul used to say Pogo was his
favorite philosopher Paul also had a
fabulous sense of humor he seemed to
have just the right story for every
occasion I cannot tell you how many
times I have repeated his story about
the Russian peasant encountering an
almost frozen bird you all have heard
the story
it ends with the three lessons I'm not
going to repeat them here ask me at the
reception he also had no difficulty
showing emotion when Paul was angry you
knew it
I recall sitting but he also had a
softer side and that is really what I
think defined Paul I was call sitting
right here in Kresge Auditorium
when Paul gave a very moving eulogy for
our colleague Jim colleton Jim as many
of you may recall died well before his
time Paul in that eulogy described how
closely he worked with Jim and
Constantine seminaries another one of
our colleagues who we lost well to
assume how they worked so hard to try
and hold this place together during the
time of student protests in the late
1960s as as Paul recalled their work
together
he described the three of them as a band
of brothers and when he did so he choked
up he loved Jim and he loved Constantine
and he was not afraid to say it
and he was not afraid to show it there
was nothing phony about Paul he was the
one of the most real people I have ever
been privileged to know a number of
other speakers have already described
described Paul's extraordinary efforts
to make MIT a better place for women and
for minorities what is less well known
on this campus is that Paul was also a
voice for gender diversity and inclusion
at Priscilla's alma mater Wheaton
College at the same time he was
president of MIT Paul chaired the
Wheaton College Board of Trustees to
this day I cannot imagine how anybody
could have done both jobs simultaneously
but Paul did
and as board chair Paul helped to bring
co-education to Wheaton a hugely
controversial decision at the time
hugely controversial Wheaton however is
the thriving vibrant college that it is
today in no small measure to Paul steady
and strong leadership of that board for
his willingness to always do the right
thing as has been said before even when
it was very very hard but my enduring
image of Paul will always be of him
walking hand-in-hand with Priscilla
across this campus Priscilla
his love of you knew no bounds thank you
for sharing him with us for so many
years and thank you for all the two of
you gave to what Paul as we've heard
many many times always called this
special place what makes it so special
is because people like you and Paul
thank you and thank you for the
opportunity to be part of this very
special ceremony today
my name is Virginia and I'm deeply
grateful to president rife for making
space in today's ceremony and tribute
for a family perspective on an a set of
stories about my father's life by him
allowing Andrew and me to speak since
MIT was central to Dad's life and love
and drive it was central to ours also
especially as we grow up in and around
campus meeting a wide and fascinating
swath of God's people and always being
stretched to learn and to grow and to
include the myriad people that our
parents thought of as family to my
mother and all our parents children
in-law children grandchildren and their
spouses and great grandchild are my
father's first family MIT in the
community here is his second my father
lived his life Full Tilt in incredibly
inclusive intentional compassion
compassionate and wholehearted ways dad
lived life in ways that left no doubt
about who he loved what he cared for who
he stood with what he stood for who and
what he was willing to work hard for how
he felt about all of us and what he
hoped his life would say after he was
gone he was passionate about his family
at home and his family in this special
place and he loved the connections
between the two
my father squeezed so very much out of
all of his days here on earth he was
fully present to us and his life had
purpose passion and focus dad was all-in
he used his time talent and treasure for
good and even though we can't really
quite yet believe that he is gone
I'm going to share first on behalf of my
amazing and remarkable sisters Amy first
and these are her words dad took us
especially me and Virginia all over the
White Mountains and Snowdonia such happy
memories on the trails beautiful scenery
and views from the top there was a kind
of magic about getting up really early
driving too near the mountain stopping
for breakfast and then doing the climb
and since food is always important to us
grace the lunches and snacks were
awesome things we didn't usually have I
remember chocolate bars and juicy orange
sections in particular the days were the
start of my deep love affair with the
great outdoors my own family made
camping and hiking a foundation of our
life together I keep thinking about all
the woodworking that Daddy has done with
all of us over the years I remember the
day when I was little probably eight or
nine years old when he came home from
MIT with a glass-fronted bookcase that
was being thrown out from a library at
MIT we turned it into my dollhouse we
put wall partitions in and wallpapered
and painted of course we even put
electricity in as well it ran out of
very large battery
I made beaded chandeliers and we use
tiny Christmas tree lights for the bulbs
it was so much fun transforming a simple
bookcase into something I wanted so much
with my father's help dad worked with my
husband Dave on several projects at our
house in Kennebunk together they rebuilt
the screened-in porch from the ground up
to the roof they repaired a very rotten
corner of our garage and over a week
they redid our kitchen including
relocating the stove rewiring the
kitchen building some new cupboards and
laying new Formica on the countertop
Dave loved working with Daddy on these
projects no one had ever done that sort
of work with him before Papa and
Stephanie built a bureau together they
started with discussing plans and what
she wanted and then they built the whole
thing over a year's time stephanie loved
it and i can attest to the
that the drawer still pulls smoothly it
was very well built I also know that dad
worked with Hannah and Priscilla on
woodworking projects he loved sharing
his skills and his love of woodworking
working with him over the past few years
it has been very clear to me how
generous he was and is even as his mind
faded he was always clear about the
organizations that he thought were
important to support and why he was also
very generous with his time and energy
with the Corps for going back to
childhood with help on homework or
projects and later with all of our
spouses and our children his
grandchildren he made himself available
and present in all our lives and this
was from a man who had lots of other
people who wanted his time and attention
also being together and spending time
knowing each other was so important to
dad he and mom fostered the love
friendship and caring that happens
between the 26 of us I am deeply
thankful for my entire family and for
the bonds that we share and I'm deeply
grateful to daddy and mom for giving all
of us that gift of family now in
Louise's words we z to get today we
celebrate my dad grandfather to my
children a supportive and proud
father-in-law to my husband Tim and a
leader at MIT I want to share memories I
have of growing up with dad dr. Paul
Gray in our home life and in our MIT
life there was a lot of overlap we had
family Friday date nights usually
Regina's pizza in the north end or
Chinese food or the Faculty Club in
Cambridge followed by big ball bowling
and MIT bowling alleys or swimming at
the MIT pool the old one which now looks
very small we loved visiting doc
edgerton's lab MIT day camp was a part
of every summer as campers and also many
years as counselors for some of us all
twelve grandchildren visited mom and dad
in the summer and loved being campers
over the years I walked to gray way
hand-in-hand with my siblings mom and
dad
and the grandchildren the gray house was
our family home for 10 years it was the
welcoming home to countless family
gathering gatherings including three
weddings Amy and Dave Andrew and Yuki
and me and Tim all got married there the
grandchildren loved playing in the what
was known then as the green forest which
is a space near the public bathrooms on
the bottom floor of the gray house and
we now the floor now the rug is white
it's probably lucky the kids have gone
we have we had two inaugurations to
attend Chancellor and then president and
both were held in the truly amazing
great courtyard
I have very many fun memories of gray
house I spent a lot of time there more
than my siblings since I am the baby I
went to Leslie University the other end
of Cambridge I recall coming home on
Friday afternoon to go on a date with my
dad I was unaware of the corporation
meeting in the large living room on the
first floor I came in singing anyone
home who loves me at the top of my lungs
to my surprise and also his I
encountered the treasurer of the
corporation at that time in the front
hall he encouraged me to be a little
quieter but dad came around the corner
with a giant dad hug he introduced me to
the corporation he made it comfortable
and not so embarrassing for me
he always loved having his kids around
to introduce to his MIT family his love
and pride were always tangible I'm sure
all my siblings our spouses and the
grandchildren will agree that education
was highly encouraged find your passion
what interests you what you were good at
and go after it don't be afraid to step
out of your comfort zone either he
encouraged the core for to pursue our
degrees and our interests and mom and
dad always encouraged us and our
partners to go after their interests our
endeavors included higher degrees
professional goals and hobbies dad also
enjoyed participating in many of our
interests with us including fishing with
Tim and Andrew home improvements travel
food wine hiking and biking
historical field trips and books on
diverse topics however I do not believe
he ever knitted it with us gray ladies
even though we invited him to join us
many times I want all of you to know
that my my dad and mom loved the core
for the for more spouses and all the
grands just like his own children
and she will conclude by sharing a
classic Weezy dad experience and really
an iconic family story learning to drive
with dad was an intense experience at
her home this is still Weezy dad was a
secret car loving junkie and he took
good care of his vehicles
he was also big on being able to follow
multi-step directions lastly he taught
that a driver needs to just drive I
think I had had some driver's ed classes
I was still very new to driving I chose
the red BMW to drive as a learner with
dad and we were on the Cape on a
beautiful morning and he said let's go
for a drive Louise he didn't call me
wheezy he called me Louise so I think
all right I have this all my safety nets
are in place the biggest of which were
the bracelets I warned my left arm many
of them really almost halfway up my arm
they were a tool that Carol school
taught me to help remember right from
left as a dyslexic kid oh I got in the
car dad said you just need to drive take
off the bracelets I tried to explain my
thoughts he said they're a distraction
just take them off well we did okay for
a while and then he gave me three
directions in a road to follow to rights
and a left well the last left turned
into a right drive through a wall of
shrubs he took it to a backyard pool
party
I had the brakes thereby causing no
damage to the guests my father looked at
me and told me to get the hell out of
here instead of driving down the
driveway in front of me I backed out
through the shrubs that I had just
driven through we went home immediately
we came into the house there was no
yelling there was no talking
it was still morning dad went to the
fridge and got a beer I went to the
bathroom and threw up after that
whenever I went driving I dad asked if I
had my bracelets on I did wear my
bracelets and from that point forward my
sister Virginia brother Andrew and mom
taught me to drive and as Virginia I'll
tell you that dad did go back that
afternoon to the house of whose shrubs
were touched to make good on the damage
lastly from Louise from September 2014
after my parents moved to Newbury Court
til about a year ago my dad and I had
dates almost every Tuesday sometimes we
did errands for the house and for Mom
sometimes we played we loved to walk the
paths on the freedom trails of course
when you spend the morning walking the
trails you need to take in some yummy
food the favorite local destination for
my dad was the colonial and in Concord
burger fries and a tall Guiness we
developed the term ten day dad and I had
many ten days and just for the record on
our Tuesday day days he told me many
times that I was a very good driver and
now my words
my father was my hero I looked up to him
and I wanted to be like him from the
earliest time I can remember I was
always proud to be his daughter he
encouraged and supported all of us he
challenged and stretched us he loved and
adored my mother my siblings and me
unconditionally and despite the
pressures and time involved in his work
he made himself emotionally available to
us through all the changes and chances
of this life all the way through my high
school years I would finish my homework
late either with him sitting in his
study or up in my room I always had a
check-in time with him before bed
he was invariably still up and working
at 11:00 or 12:00 at night and when he
woke me up at 5:00 a.m. with a very loud
electric buzzer he installed in my third
floor bedroom he loved to lean on that
thing dad at 5:00 a.m. was always shaved
showered and dressed that was his work
ethic he never complained about his
hours or his work it was just what he
did he often shared stories about
encounters that pleased or inspired him
at MIT or a project he was working on
that excited him or how he won a squash
game that day Daddy was passionate about
his work and the people he worked
alongside he cared deeply for all the
people God put in his path his
principled honesty openness and
unwavering decency always on display and
his deeds and his words were a life
lesson and a life map for the four of us
my parents welcomed all comers to our
home and treated each visiting student
or academic like esteemed family I
wanted to be a doctor of medicine when I
was in high school in 1975 I graduated
high school and I went to a decent
liberal arts college and started the
pre-med curriculum I had done well in
high school but chemistry and math had
definitely not been my strong or long
suit and yes you might see an emerging
theme here amongst the children the
first semester of my freshman year was a
disaster the first failing grades I had
ever earned in my life were in that
semester
I had to drop organic chemistry in
chemistry and I only barely passed
calculus because I rode the Greyhound
bus home every other weekend so the dad
could help me with my problem sets
he sat patiently next to me as I worked
the problems never doing them for me but
helping me see the process and the ways
to a solution that year during Christmas
vacation dad sat down with me and in the
most tender and loving way imaginable he
gently suggested that I and I quote him
here make my studies match my gifts his
words I took his advice and moved in a
different direction it made dad smile
when I ended up working in healthcare
ministry for 15 years healing work from
a different perspective I know he was
proud of me and he was proud of my
husband and offered so much invaluable
support and encouragement to Tom as he
worked on his PhD dad was present when
Tom got his degree in May of 2014 and I
think dad was more excited when Tom's
book was published than we were dad knew
what effort and commitment the degree in
the book required and he was delighted
the fact that the book was a history
book about engineering made it kind of
perfect I want to end by reflecting on
my father's character his excellent kind
and loyal aide Faja me stood over his
bed two days before dad died and said
quote Paul goes the extra distance
unquote this was true throughout his
life dad was our very own resident wise
men he could fix any broken thing solve
any stubborn problem dry a flood of
adolescent girl tears picked the
splinters out of our hands and feet
comfort the lovelorn or lonely designing
an adventure or plan an amazing trip
helped with our math science social
studies and English homework and keep a
watchful but low-key eye on our social
lives he fought for real people and
authentic inclusion for equity and
justice he generally care he genuinely
cared about people and causes and he had
a sturdy steady solid no-nonsense with a
twinkle way about
him the first time I ever saw my father
cry was when the Reverend dr. Martin
Luther King was assassinated the second
time was when he had to put our first
family dog down dad was part Terrier
part bull dog part teddy bear he never
expected anything of us that he didn't
expect of himself and his generosity
knew no limits dad was both strict and
fair he was often reserved but his
natural way of listening more than he
spoke manifested a tender heart and an
unparalleled knack for connection and
relationship my father was a man who
could be trusted and relied upon in
every situation and circumstance of life
and as his granddaughter Caroline puts
it in his in quote his knowledge of all
the things despite dads success and
steadily advancing career my father was
a deeply humble man he was always more
comfortable in yard work clothes and
dress up attire and when he was out in
the world he didn't need to be carefully
kept and he didn't crave special
attention he also had a vast
appreciation for the people who work
behind the scenes to make things go and
he was fiercely loyal two stories
demonstrate these qualities
amiri calls her move-in day at Wheaton
College where he had just been appointed
the chairman of the board I quote Amy
here dad was named chair of the board
the summer before I entered Wheaton as a
freshman the day we arrived on campus to
drop me off we pulled into the parking
area closest to Stanton Hall where I
lived my first year it was not terribly
close but we were in good company and we
were managing a security officer
recognized dad and said dr. gray you can
pull right up in front of the building
it will be much easier to unload from
their dad without a single pause said
thank you but we are fine where we are
with all the other families today I am
the father of an incoming student now I
quote Martha Milliken Weezy's childhood
BFF who is here today Paul Gray has been
a part of my life for a very long time
he was so very gentle and kind to me
growing up my dad wasn't around very
much and doctor
she took me in as one of their own and
boy could they cook in the early years
Paul would come pick me up in the
morning so easy and I could go to school
together hand in hand I remember him
being concerned that such little people
shouldn't walk so far alone I knew I was
a lucky girl I was often included in
gray family vacations overnights at
Sheffield Road had two young girls
staying up way too late with vast amount
of giggling overnights at the
president's house were always filled
with adventure lots of doors more good
food and the all-important girl time
after I graduated from college I worked
for Wellington management and MIT was
one of our firm's first large
institutional was our firms largest
institutional client
whenever dr. gray was coming to
Wellington for one of the frequent
investment management meetings there
would be a buzz in the building I was
not involved in managing mi t--'s money
but each and every time that Paul
entered the offices he would make a
point of finding me and giving me one of
those wonderful bear hugs he always made
time to check on me and everybody
wondered why the president of MIT was
finding Martha sometimes bearing flowers
or taking her out to dinner I knew it
was because I was a lucky girl and he
was a lovely man there is a view out
there in the world that says that
whoever we are is accentuated by our
aging I believe that this is largely
true watching what disease did to our
father over the past seven years is one
of the cruelest things that I have ever
witnessed
however as Alzheimer's disease slowly
robbed and stripped our father of his
brilliance competence intellect vast
knowledge problem solving skills
woodworking gifts and love of reading
writing and teaching the essential daddy
or Paul still remained with his dignity
intact the man who loved people who was
humble to his very core the joyful
gentle man the teddy bears man who
trusted God who lit up whenever his wife
a child including his in-law children or
a grandchild walked into the room the
friendly hospitable and open gentleman
who gave hugs or stuck out his hand
whether or not he could
number the person standing in front of
him the sweet and affectionate father
dedicated mentor and colleague devoted
to his colleagues and his school this
man was with us to the very end of his
life maybe it is in politic to say this
here at MIT which is an international
leader of scientific research and is at
the forefront of all things tech but I'm
gonna say it anyway my father was a man
of faith
he knew God's grace and he knew Jesus's
name he always thought that the
arguments between sacred scripture and
science were silly tangent dad perceived
the spark of the divine in the work of
scientists and engineers across the
Institute and in the best of human
collaboration and concentrated effort to
discover invent learn teach share and
advance anew dad saw the hand of God at
work because he worshiped a loving God
and was a keen observer of human beings
and behaviors he also knew that
sometimes we sabotage ourselves Larry
pointed out his email address we have
met the enemy and he is us Pogo his
favorite tag line dad knew and
understood that to be human is to
experience a million good friday moments
moments of sadness challenge betrayal
hardship suffering and pain but dad also
knew a resurrection Jesus the Lord of
love and light and love and and love
light and life the Lord who revealed by
his living and his dying and by rising
again that death does not help the last
word darkness does not prevail love
always wins there are risks to being
human accidents and illness and tragedy
unfold bodies get old and disease
happens beloved ones die and the world
seems to shift and we wonder if we can
move forward but the truth of my
father's faith is that love never dies
relationship changes but does not end
we carry our deceased loved ones forward
in our hearts in the way we live and
remember and celebrate we don't say
goodbye we say until we meet again
I saw God over and over again in these
last painful years of my father's life I
saw God and the care and love our mother
extended to dad every waking minute
every single day I saw it in the care
and love that this extraordinary
community of MIT extended to data mom
and to us as dad's health failed God was
in a small intimate moments of
connection spark joy and recognition
that dad savored right to the end of his
life the last week of his life as we
waited and watched and sat vigil now
looks a lot like a parting gift from dad
the gift of connection and love between
our mother the core for the four more
and the extended and beloved tribe of
grandchildren who are more like siblings
than cousins memories and stories tears
and laughter good food prepared and
shared favorite stories read aloud and
lots of hugs and hand-holding prepared
all of us to let go it takes a village
to raise a child it turns out it also
takes a village to help an elder die
with dignity and in comfort and to help
the bereaved family move forward you are
all key parts of our village thank you
for all you have done to support my
father and mother and our family on this
final leg of my father's journey thank
you for the gift of your presence and
esteem for the gift of your love and
devotion thank you for showing us love
over and over in ways that will sustain
us and carry us forward in the days to
come
may our cherished father and your
cherish leader rest in peace and may we
honor him Paul dad dr. gray may we honor
him in his legacy by our love by our
character and our compassion by our
courage and our conviction by our
willingness to do
good in the world by always telling the
truth and by our commitment to family
community honest hard work and all of
God's people amen
I'm Bob Maillard the 11th chairman of mi
t--'s corporation polls routes at MIT
run deep and they run wide he came here
in 1950 that was the same year I was
born and from that point forward whether
as an undergraduate or a graduate
student or a professor or a Chancellor
associate provost president chairman
advisor or mentor Paul has had been an
integral active and important part of mi
t--'s fabric in fact his presence here
spanned almost half of mi t--'s entire
existence and while that statistic alone
is amazing it doesn't begin to reflect
all that Paul meant to us through his
friendship and his leadership his wisdom
his foresight and his energy and his
youth there's some here who may not have
had the joy of knowing Paul personally
and there are and will be many many more
in the future who will be denied that
honor nonetheless we are and ever will
be the common beneficiaries of his good
work in his good life that is I believe
what it means to have done so much to
build and nourish this great institution
of MIT we're grateful that Paul's family
continues to be part of MIT and it's an
honor to acknowledge and think and to
thank them Paul's wife Priscilla his son
Andrew and his daughter Virginia I'd
like to thank Raphael Shirley Victor Jim
Susan Gerald Andrew Larry Virginia for
their poignant reflections as well as
Marcus and David for the beautiful music
I'd also like to thank the MIT police
and the MIT ROTC for their presentations
to the flags
I'd like to invite all of you to join
Paul's family in the Kresge Oval for a
reception at the conclusion of this
service and I think it's now I want to
introduce the MIT corollaries who will
sing the school song and pulls honor and
I'd like to thank the students for being
here and invite everyone to join with
them during the second verse thank you
[Music]
once more
you
[Music]